[موسيقى]
العفراء عفراسات سمعت افلام مصوره درست في
جامعه النيلين كليه الاداب جسم المكتبات
والمعلومات لكن ما اشتغلت في الحياه
[موسيقى]
كلام في مجال ده ممكن تكون كانت شويه
الحاجه دي كانت يعني
مشتغل
دوره تدريبيه اذا كان محمد
اكبر
ممكن يكون فيها مشاكل
[موسيقى]
يا استاذ اكمل الاساتذه كان دايما انه اي
حاجه انا اعملها كان بالنسبه لابني ممكن
يكون المرجع الاساسي لانه ده صح وده غلط
لو كان عملت كده كان بيكون افضل من كده
ودي كلها كانت بالنسبه للدروس مجانيه انا
بقدر اا يعني في خطوات اللي قدامكم
[موسيقى]
دائما بتكون انت امراه موجوده في المجال
لانه يعني انا اللي فتره طويله
اشتغلت في المجال ده كنت عارفه
عموما
يعني هو في الحاجه دي بالنسبه لي كانت
شويه كانت تحدي كبير اني انا اكون موجوده
في الحاجه دي وانه انا هاثبت صوت لانه
الحياه دائما على الثقه بتاعه العمل همم
التحديات ممكن كان بتكون في الموضوع يعني
مثلا كثير بسيطه
بالنسبه لي بيكون ناعم همم
يعني في الموقع
او كده في مرات بتحسي انه صوتك مع مجهول
اول الكلام اللي انت بتقوله او الاردن انت
بتقوله نفسه او ما بيتم الاستجابه ليه وبس
كبيره
[موسيقى]
دايما في السودان اذا حصلوا المشكله
بتاعتهم او كده النساء بيخافوا انه يقولوا
لان الموضوع ده ممكن يكون سر ممتاز
الاكبر ممكن يسبب احرار للعائلات وكده
فالح لكن الانتهاك هو موجود فهما للجهاز
موجود المفروض يتوسع المفروض يتنشر
المفروض الناس تعرف المفروض ده المجموعات
الثانيه مركز
الجسر خبريه بشكل مختلف
او الحروف
[موسيقى]
نجاح لانه لفترات طويله كنا بنتكلم عن
الحروب عن الانتهاكات بشكل عام بدون ما
نركز بالاقضا النساء
وكانت دي فرصه كبيره جدا انه نحن نتكلم
عنه
تليفون بيحصل اقتصاد جماعي بيحصل اقتصاد
انتهاكات غير برضو احسن
ما نتكلم عن الحاجات الحساسه
[موسيقى]
جاهزه
للافارقه اللي بيشتغلوا في مجالات العمل
فيها
وبيقدموا لهم الدعم
والمنشوره والصبار
ولا ممكن تكون النوع من التغذيه
انا تم ترشيحه من قبل منظمه وعد والاستاذ
الزهري حيدر وبعدها تم تسديد في من بعد
الاعضاء في افريكانو لازم من السودان
بعدها قبل سته اشهر
في الفيديو بتاعه الترشيح دي ساعه ثانيه
همم
[موسيقى]